die hitzig würden sie im Moment die
Atmosphäre die Stimmung im Land
beschreiben wie gespannt ich bin höchst
besorgt vor allem in Ostdeutschland
das ist jetzt überhaupt kein Vorwurf an
die Mitbürger in Ostdeutschland sondern
dort wird Protest aus einer
politikwissenschaftlichen Erklärung
könnte jetzt der so untermauern stärker
emotionaler formuliert aber es hat
erstens natürlich mit der
wirtschaftlichen Lage der Angst davor
der Inflation
Rezessionsangst Energiekrise Preise
Arbeitsplätze auch das Thema Mittelstand
und gepaart auch mit dem Thema
Migration ist ja auch Thema der heutigen
Sendung
Migrationsbewegungen neues 2015 das
alles zusammen
produziert einen Protest für eine ich
sage rechtsextreme Partei die nicht
einmal an dieser Stelle Personen hat mit
dem man sich irgendwo hoffentlich nicht
identifiziert sondern eigentlich nur
eine Bewegung ist ein Ventil ist und ja
da haben wir als cdu/csu auch für
nachzuholen weil wir werden an dieser
Stelle nicht als die
Opposition wahrgenommen sie
Niedersachsen sondern der Protest
formuliert sich viel radikaler und das
macht mich schon betroffen in
Niedersachsen durchweg ob jetzt in
Städten oder auch am flachen Land
zwischen sieben und 12 13 14 Prozent
also wir haben da einen einen
Prozentanteil wo alle Parteien nicht nur
Tränendrüsen drücken und
betroffenheitsminen sondern wir müssen
uns auch um die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
an dieser Stelle kümmern und eine
Antwort geben und ich glaube dass wir da
schon gesagt haben und wenn Herr Lucke
AFD gegründet hätte wäre sicherlich noch
CDU Mitglied aber das wäre nur ein
frommer Wunsch sie haben das gerade
schon gesagt Herr scheuer inmitten
dieser tiefen Energiekrise gerade
corona-krise so ganz bisschen
abgefrühstückt scheint hinter uns zu
liegen ist aber noch nicht ganz tot mit
Blick auf Herbst und Winter kommt eine
neue Krise wieder hoch seit 2015 zwei 16
die höchsten Flüchtlingszahlen im
Muttermale sind damals zu uns gekommen
aus Syrien 2015 sind durch ein Foto ganz
berühmt geworden ihre persönliche
Geschichte durch ein selfie mit der
Kanzlerin was machen sie heute also mir
geht es erstmal schon viel besser als
2015 heute studiere ich ich bin am 15
Semester habe ich meine Studium schon
fast hinter mir studiere
wirtschaftskommunikationen der Berliner
HTW und mache gerade meine Praktikum bei
dir Deutsche Welle schon jetzt mein
dritter Monat und macht mir Spaß und es
geht mir schon viel besser und heute da
ich die Sprache erst mal gelernt habe ja
kann ich in der Gesellschaft schon
besser integrieren und verstehen es ist
keine
durchschnittsbiografie von all denen die
2015 2 16 zu ihnen gekommen sind also zu
uns gekommen sind also Durchschnitt was
war die Frage noch mal sie sind
überdurchschnittlich ja
durchschnittlich gut deutsch es ist eine
außergewöhnliche flüchtlingsbiographie
die meisten ist das bis heute nicht
gelungen also es hängt von Menschen ich
denke aber es ist mal ähm ich spreche
mich noch nicht so perfekt aber ich gebe
natürlich nur weil ich das will und das
betrifft Menschen die auch so innere
Motivation sag ich mal haben und wie wir
sehen viele Menschen haben auch die
Sprache gelernt also ich bin kein
Ausnahme sondern es gibt viele die das
auch geschafft haben also ich habe
vielleicht die Möglichkeit bekommen
nachdem ich dasselbe mit die
Bundeskanzlerin gemacht habe Menschen
kennenzulernen und das hilft natürlich
bei der Integration also man sollte
schon beide Seite schauen die
Integration läuft ja von beiden Seiten
von die Deutschen und von die Menschen
die aus aus dem Kriegsgebiet auch kommen
um hier Sicherheit zu haben ja also
jetzt haben sie auch deswegen so eine
ungewöhnliche Geschichte weil sie sich
heute für ukrainische Flüchtlinge
engagieren und weil sie verlobt sind mit
einer Frau die ihre Wurzeln in der
Ukraine hat genau also ich habe das
erste mal selber erlebt wie schwierig
ist das wenn man hier in den neuen Land
ist ich habe das alles so Schritte
erlebt neues im Land alles ist so
komplett neu und die Menschen brauchen
dringend Hilfe und das sind halt ja
Frauen mit Kinder dann bin ich bei der
rotes Kreuz ich habe die Situation näher
geschaut und ich mit meiner Freundin die
aus Kiel kommt auch sind wir unterwegs
und helfen ganz viele ukrainische
Familien die in Berlin leben und die
brauchen wirklich Hilfe die die sind
ohne ihre Partner dann hier gekommen und
sind traurig brauchen dringend Hilfe und
es am Anfang war die Bereitschaft da
aber ich sehe immer das ist immer
weniger wird was das nicht passieren
durfte also die Menschen sollen immer da
sein wirklich und vielleicht in eine
Unterkunft gehen die Situation da
schauen also die Menschen brauchen
Freunde sag ich mal die mit denen
unterhalten können weil wir das
möglicherweise erscheuer gar nicht
schaffen können inmitten dieser Krise
Tiefe Energiekrise wir haben gerade von
allen Seiten hier von freiengelenkäfer
von Herrn Lucke von Herrn Scheffler von
ihnen selbst gehört wie dramatisch die
Lage ist und jetzt haut eine neue
flüchtlingskrise dran und immer mehr
Menschen stellen die Frage ja Leute wie
soll das gehen verstehen sie das also
nur ein starkes Deutschland kann anderen
helfen und das ist anders wie 2015 da
kommt jetzt kommen jetzt zwei
Entwicklungen zusammen nämlich die die
mir im ersten Teil der Sendung
diskutiert haben und natürlich auch die
Angst und die Besorgnis in der
Bevölkerung und zum anderen natürlich
die Verantwortung für die vielen
Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine wir
haben über eine Million bei uns
aufgenommen das ist zehnfach das was
Frankreich aufgenommen hat also wir
stellen uns wieder der Verantwortung
leider nicht zu viele in Europa und
jetzt kommt noch eine zweite und das
darf man nicht
übereinander legen über die Balkanroute
eine neue Migrationswelle die uns alles
abverlangt alles abverlangt und ich habe
Sorge dass das zum gesellschaftlichen
Sprengstoff wird aber auch zur
wirklichen ja
für unsere demokratischen Grundfeste
weil diese Überlagerung der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung der Sorgen
der Menschen und einer zusätzlichen
Migrationswelle eben nicht die
Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine das
ist ein eine Melange gepaart und es der
Gedanke dazu oben drauf dass wir mit den
Koalition mit dem Koalitionsvertrag der
Ampel und den Vorkehrungen die vom
Bürgergeld angefangen bis zum
Spurwechsel zu sozialen Vergünstigungen
zu Bezugsmöglichkeiten
vieles Land gibt
in Europa macht und das wäre
lass uns einen Moment über die Situation
sprechen wie dramatisch ist die Lage
schon im Moment im Moment wenn wir keine
Energiekrise hätten vermutlich würden
wir ausschließlich über flüchtlingskrise
gerade berichten über sehr viele
Ukrainer die zu uns kommen aber auch
sehr viele die über die Balkanroute
wieder zu uns kommen die Zahlen sind da
dramatisch gestiegen es gibt
Alarmsignale von den Landräten vor allen
Dingen aus den Gemeinden wir können
einen Fall einmal aus Bayern zeigen der
uns aufgeschreckt hat in diesen Tagen
der kommt aus der Nähe von München ganz
genau bei Fürstenfeldbruck und da
entsteht ein ganz neuer Konflikt und das
nur weil die Landräte und die
Bürgermeister verzweifelt nach Platz
suchen für immer mehr ankommende
Flüchtlinge
ein Seniorenheim das nun auch zum
Flüchtlingsheim wird oberschweinbach
nordwestlich von München das
Seniorenheim am Klostergarten 2008
eingeweiht inzwischen 137 Plätze
bestens um sorgt so ist das Motto der
Einrichtung jetzt soll das Seniorenheim
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen 80 das komplette
Erdgeschoss wird zur
Flüchtlingsunterkunft wer jahrelang
unten sein Zuhause hatte musste raus ins
Obergeschoss umziehen wie Hannelore
Gärtner und Ursula Hellwig beide 83
Jahre alt beide mussten für die
ankommenden Flüchtlinge ihre Wohnungen
Räumen nun leben sie auf einem Flur mit
schwer dementen
es ist nicht so wie es mir vorgestellt
habe weil da ist ein Theater manchmal da
oben gell
die dem Menschen die schmeißen
das dahin alles Wasser der eine Holstein
Bipa drauf sind Puller dahinten und
alles so eine Sache Pflegebedürftige die
ziehen müssen um Platz für Flüchtlinge
zu machen zunächst ukrainische auch
bürgermeister Norbert Riepel rechnet mit
Konflikten es werden
Leute einziehen Kinder bis zu
Erwachsenen Herren mit unterschiedlichen
oder ganz anderen Lebensgewohnheiten und
Tagesabläufen als es eben
pflegebedürftige Personen in am Heim
haben und das wird insbesondere abends
aber auch tagsüber sehr viel Unruhe im
Heim selber im Gartenbereich oder auch
in den Nachbargärten verursachen die
Folge ein Wachdienst vier
Sicherheitsleute sollen das Heim nun
rund um die Uhr bewachen doch wer hat
all das entschieden der Bürgermeister
glaubt am Ende ging es ums Geld das
Pflegeheim hat seit ein zwei Jahren hier
zwei Jahren Riesenprobleme Personal zu
finden
Pflegepersonal zu finden insofern wurden
Räume dann zwangsläufig mussten leer
gelassen werden und man hat jetzt
entschieden das Erdgeschoss zu räumen
und das dann extern zu vermieten um
einfach Ersatz Einnahmen zu generieren
ein Seniorenheim wird auch zum
Flüchtlingsheim und selbst der
zuständige Landrat weist jede Schuld von
sich er müsse eben immer neue
Unterkünfte bieten für immer neue
Flüchtlinge ich bekomme jede Woche 50
Menschen vor der Tür gestellt und muss
sie unterbringen und muss dafür sorgen
dass sie im Winter nicht erfrieren oder
verhungern und das muss ich tun und
deswegen muss ich notfalls auch zur
Beschlagnahme greifen natürlich nicht
von Häusern oder Wohnungen aber von
Gewerbeimmobilien oder ähnlichem wenn
sie leer stehen ein Landkreis am Limit
immer mehr Flüchtlinge und so müssen den
oberschweinbach nun sie Platz machen
Pflegebedürftige für Flüchtlinge
Herr scheuert dass es nah an ihrer
Heimat Pflegeheimbewohner die jetzt
umziehen teilweise auch umziehen wollen
aber umziehen müssen um Platz zu machen
für Flüchtlinge weil der Landrat der
Bürgermeister einfach kein Platz mehr
haben ja weil wir untersprechen nicht
von den ukrainischen Kriegsflüchtlingen
sondern weil wir jeden Tag jeden Werktag
einen vierstelligen eine vierstellige
Zahl an Zugängen haben vor allem auch
zum ukrainische Flüchtlinge in dem Fall
nicht nur nicht nur erstmal um Ukraine
aber später zum Beispiel zum Beispiel
Zentrum in meiner Heimat sind 500 Plätze
aber 1500 Personen die jetzt
tagesaktuell darstellen ich habe noch
mehr nachgefragt
natürlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied
jetzt erstmal wenn die die Wohnung
verlassen müssen wegen eines Syrers oder
wegen eines sugarin erstmal relativ egal
okay ich kann jetzt den einen Fall nicht
beurteilen nur eins ist klar dass wir
dadurch zwei verschärfte Situationen
bekommen und wenn zum Beispiel andere
Nachbarstaaten Europa jetzt das auch
schon gelernt haben wie man Flüchtlinge
weiter schiebt nach Deutschland die
Österreicher verteilen Bahntickets dass
sie dann von der von der Grenze die
Obergrenze durchgekämpft aber wir sind
ja immer an der Regierung also das heißt
unser Grundprinzip war Steuern ordnen
und begrenzen und das ist auch heute
noch wir haben letzte Woche aber das
letzte Woche in Deutschland Bundestag
haben wir einen Antrag
Obergrenze mit ihnen eine
flüchtlingsobergrenze wir müssen jetzt
stoppen natürlich wir brauchen jetzt
natürlich auch für ukrainische
Flüchtlinge nein deswegen habe ich sehr
Unterschieden was ist die Unterschiede
die Unterscheidung nein Frau Engelke wir
waren uns einigen Stopp Stopp Stopp wir
waren uns einig EU aus jetzt lassen wir
mal Ukraine Krieg Weg EU-Außengrenzen
gilt für das Asylverfahren und des
Asylverfahren ist über Jahre nicht
europäisch geregelt worden die
Außengrenze gilt das Verfahren muss klar
sein aber diese jetzt
überhaupt diese Regierung macht
eigentlich den den falschen Dreh nämlich
pull-effekte noch zusätzlich
zu machen jetzt passiert ist das eine
Personengruppen gegen eine andere
ausgespielt wird hier in diesem Fall
sind die Pflegeheimbewohner gegen die
Flüchtlinge die da reinkommen
nein das ist regulär es geht jetzt hier
auch um reguläre Migration also ich bin
strikt dagegen dass wir hier anfangen
Obergrenzen einzuführen die Diskussionen
sie leben doch auch in Europa
dafür gibt es keine Obergrenze das darf
auch nicht sein und
ich nicht
aber da und das zweite ist wie begründen
sie denn eine zwei Klassensituation von
Migrationen
gleich zurück mit einem Streit in dieser
flüchtlingskrise zurück hier bei Bild
bis gleich mittendrin und zurück bei
Bild die richtigen Fragen und wir
streiten in dieser so tiefen Krise über
eine neue Krise die immer mehr dazu
kommt die flüchtlingskrise und andreas
Scheuer ist bei uns zu Gast und hat eben
eine Aufnahmestopp gefordert hier für
alle außer ukrainischen Flüchtlingen
freien Käfer sagt völlig dagegen der
einzige am Tisch der hier gerade mit
regiert aktiv ist Fang Schäffler FDP
Bundestagsabgeordnete Aufnahme Stopp
jetzt sagt andreas Scheuer also wir
brauchen vor allem eine europäische
Regelung ja das machen
man kann nicht innerhalb Europas die
Grenzen abbauen oder haben sie recht es
wird auch gemacht
der der oder an den EU-Außengrenzen
hält man diese Grenzen nicht robust und
dafür haben wir ja frontext geschaffen
die letztendlich
alle anderen verschärfen wir müssen uns
beiden gerade über eine flüchtlingskrise
und wir verschieben das Problem
gerade auch mit eurem Paket sprechen
über eine neue flüchtlingskrise in
diesem Jahr 2022 in diesem Herbst und
Winter wir haben die Zahlen vorliegen
weit über eine Million Flüchtlinge von
denen die meisten Ukraine sind und wir
sagen Ukraine sind aber ausgenommen die
sind total willkommen können wir das
dass die Frage stellen sich im Moment
ganz viele Menschen können wir das mit
Blick auf den Herbst und Winter wo wir
wissen Franzosen haben zum Beispiel kaum
Flüchtlinge bisher aufgenommen aus der
Ukraine können wir die alle in
Deutschland aufnehmen wenn es noch mal
eine massive Fluchtwelle im Herbst und
Winter gibt aus der Ukraine das ist
natürlich immer eine Frage wie groß ist
diese Fluchtwelle aber im Augenblick
wird es nicht so als er das unbelastbar
wir müssen diese Fluchtbewegung aus der
Ukraine die wir im Februar März April
gehabt haben die ist ja auf eine
unglaubliche Bereitschaft in der
Bevölkerung gestoßen diese Leute privat
das hat der Moderne auch genau also ich
kann das nur jetzt meine eigene
Perspektive sagen diese Bereitschaft ist
nicht ausgeschöpft worden also ich meine
meine Frau und ich wir haben das
angebunden ich war wir haben zwei mal
einen Anruf gekriegt ist nie ein Ukraine
bei uns aufgekreuzt ja ich glaube es
gibt nach wie vor diese
Aufnahmebereitschaft in der Bevölkerung
ukrainische das klar ja auch im
Privathaushalt sie wollten einen
Flüchtlingen aufnehmen aus der Ukraine
und es ist keiner gekommen keiner
gekommen war zu weit weg von Hamburg ja
oder Sie wollen Lucke nein nein nein
bestimmt nicht sondern es ist so dass
wir halt ein bisschen außerhalb von
Hamburg leben Winsen an der Ruhr ja 30
km weg oder sowas und dann hieß es nein
wir sind schon in Hamburg und wir sind
die Kinder schon eingeschult und da
haben wir medizinische Versorgung und
unten solche Sachen also die Leute waren
sehr sehr schnell irgendwo untergebracht
teilweise bei Freunden und Bekannten die
selbst aus der Ukraine stammen teilweise
bei Gastfamilien da meines Erachtens ist
es so dass die Aufnahmebereitschaft der
Bevölkerung nach wie vor enorm hoch ist
und dass da auch durchaus noch Kapazität
sind deshalb sehe ich bei den
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen im Augenblick
jedenfalls
genau
auf privates Engagement aber das scheint
ja nicht so viele Leute
Abonnenten
wir das ist bei jeder der Bürger sich
engagiert Flüchtlinge aufnimmt aber
bei mir so wir müssen sagen ja
ukrainische Flüchtlinge ich sage auch
dazu jeder muss wissen bei vollem
Leistungsbezug und auch die Möglichkeit
das heißt beispielsweise in den
Arbeitsmarkt zu gehen wenigstens für die
Zeit ist dafür ja
okay gesagt wir haben doch die
Möglichkeit ja das haben wir ja gemacht
migrationspolitische Sonderweg für die
andere Gruppe die ich meine also
Balkanroute heißt für die Ampel
Bleiberecht reduzieren
fachkräfteeinwanderung aufweichen
Familiennachzug erleichtern
chancenaufenthaltsrecht weichgestalten
Asylsystem unterlaufen
sie sagen Herrn Scheffler er sorgt dafür
dass die Zahlen weiter steigen ja
natürliche Ebene da eine stärker Rolle
übernehmen muss das ist aus meiner ja
aber das National das ist der Punkt das
ist doch eine eine binnensicht
entscheidend ist das die Europäische
Union an den
anfangsgrenzen entsprechen ich dachte
sie sagen das ist eine Binse eine Binse
ist es nämlich auch und das sind die
selben Binsen die wir seit sechs oder
sieben Jahren haben und deshalb
und genau deswegen habe ich aufpassen
genau darüber weil dieser Streit schon
so lange geht genau deswegen habe ich
mit dem österreichischen Ex-Kanzler mit
Sebastian Kurz über genau dieses Problem
besprechen und Sebastian Kurz erhebt im
Grunde dieselben Forderungen wie 2015
zwei 16 ich habe mit ihm über diese neue
flüchtlingskrise hier bei Bild
gesprochen
wenn man hier nicht gegensteuert wenn es
nicht schnell Druck von Seiten der
Europäischen Union gibt diese illegalen
Migrationsströme wieder zu stoppen dann
werden die Zahlen weiter massiv
ansteigen und wir werden in manchen
Ländern nahe an das kommen was wir im
Jahr 2015 oder 2016 erlebt haben ich
glaube es zeigt einfach dass seine
Überforderung des System gibt es zeigt
das zu Recht unsere Systeme nicht darauf
ausgelegt sind unbegrenzt Menschen
aufzunehmen ich habe nicht den Eindruck
Europa im Moment sehr gut gerüstet ist
ich glaube aber dass es
relativ einfach wäre da wieder einen
richtigen Weg einzuschlagen es ist aus
2015 und den Folgejahren eigentlich
bekannt was gemacht werden muss nämlich
nicht wegzusehen nicht das Problem klein
zu reden nicht
die Politik der offenen Grenzen zu
verfolgen sondern an den Außengrenzen
Menschen zu stoppen Schlepper konsequent
zu verfolgen und auch zu bestrafen